when a major league baseball player
throws a fastball that balls definitely
got kinetic energy we know that because
if you get in the way you can do work on
you that's going to hurt you got to
watch help but here's my question does
the fact that most pitches unless you're
throw-in a knuckleball does the fact
that most pitches head toward home plate
with the baseball spinning mean that
that ball has extra kinetic energy well
it does and how do we figure that out
that's the that's the goal for this
video how do we determine what the
rotational kinetic energy is of an
object well if I was coming out this for
the first time my first guess I'd say
okay I say I know what regular kinetic
energy looks like the formula for
regular kinetic energy is just one-half
MV squared so I'd say all right I want
rotational kinetic energy let me just
call that K rotational and what is that
going to be well I know for objects that
are rotating the rotational equivalent
of mass is moment of inertia so I might
guess all right instead of mass I'd have
moment of inertia because in Newton's
second law for rotation I know that
instead of math there's a moment of
inertia so maybe I replace that and
instead of speed squared maybe since I
have something rotating I'd have angular
speed squared and it turns out this
works so you can often derive not really
a derivation you're just kind of
guessing educated ly but you can often
get the formula for the rotational
analog of some linear formula by just
substituting the rotational analog for
each of the variables so if I replace
mass with rotational mass I get the
moment of inertia if I replace speed
with rotational speed I get the angular
speed and this is the correct formula so
in this video we need to derive this
because that it's not really in
derivation we didn't really prove this
we just showed that it's plausible how
do we prove that this is the rotational
kinetic energy of an object that's
rotating like a baseball well the first
thing to recognize is that this
rotational kinetic energy isn't really a
new kind of kinetic energy it's still
just the same old regular kinetic energy
for something that's rotating and what I
mean by that is this so imagine this
baseball that's rotating in a circle
every point on that baseball is moving
with some speed so what I mean
by that is this so this point at the top
here imagine this little piece of the
leather right here it's going to have
some speed forward I'm going to call
this mass m1 that little piece of mass
right there and I'll call the speed of
it v1 similarly this point on the
leather right there I'm going to call it
m2 it's going to be moving down because
this is rotating in a circle so I'll
call that v2 and points closer to the
axis are going to be moving with smaller
speed so this point right here we'll
call it m3 moving down with a speed V 3
that is not as big as v2 or v1 I you
can't see that very well I'll use a
darker green so this m3 right here
closer to the axis axis being right at
this point in the center closer to the
axis so it's speed is smaller than
points that are farther away from this
axis so you can see this is kind of
complicated all points on this baseball
are going to be moving with different
speeds so points over here that are
really close to the axes barely moving
at all I'll call this m4 and it would be
moving at speed V for what we mean by
the rotational kinetic energy is really
just all the regular kinetic energy
these masses have about the center of
mass of the baseball so in other words
what we mean by K rotational is you just
add up all of these energies you'd have
1/2 this little piece of leather up here
would have some kinetic energy so you do
one-half m1 v1 squared plus and this m2
has some kinetic energy don't worry that
it points downward downward doesn't
matter for things that aren't vectors
this V gets squared so kinetic energy is
not a vector so it doesn't matter that
one velocity points down because this is
just speed and similarly you'd add up
1/2 m3 the three squared but you might
be like this is impossible there's
infinitely many points in this baseball
how am I ever going to do this well
something magical was about to happen
this is one of my favorite little
derivations it's short and sweet because
watch what happens k irrotational is
really just the sum if I add all these
up I can write it as a sum of all the
one-half MV squared zuv every point on
this baseball so imagine breaking this
baseball up into very very small pieces
don't do it physically but just think
about it mentally just visualize
considering very small pieces particles
of this baseball and how fast they're
going what I'm saying is that if you add
all of that up you get the total
rotational kinetic energy this looks
impossible to do but something magical
is about to happen and here's what we
can do we can rewrite see the problem
here is V all these points have a
different speed V but we can use a trick
a trick that we love to use in physics
instead of writing this as V we're going
to write V as so remember that for
things that are rotating V is just R
times Omega the radius how far from the
axis you are times the angular velocity
or the angular speed gives you the
regular speed this formula is really
handy so we're going to replace V with R
Omega and this is going to give us R
Omega and you still have to square it
and at this point you probably thinking
like this is even worse what did we do
this for we'll watch if we add the stuff
I have 1/2 M I'm going to get an R
squared and an Omega squared and the
reason this is better is that even
though every point on this baseball has
a different speed V they all have the
same angular speed Omega that was what
was good about these angular quantities
is that they're the same for every point
on the baseball no matter how far away
you are from the axis and since they're
the same for every point I can bring
that out of the summation so I can
rewrite this summation and bring
everything that's constant for all of
the masses out of the summation so I can
write this as 1/2 times the summation of
M times R squared and end that quantity
end of that summation and just pull the
Omega squared out because it's the same
for each term I'm basically factoring
this out of all of these terms in the
summation it's like up here all of these
have a 1/2 you can imagine factoring out
a 1/2 and just writing this whole
quantity as 1/2 times m1 v1 squared plus
m2 v2 squared and so on that's what I'm
doing down here for the 1/2 and for the
Omega squared so that's what was good
about replacing V with R Omega D Omega
is the same for all of them you can
bring that out you might still be
concerned you might be like we're still
stuck with the M in here because you've
got different M's at different
and we're stuck with all these R
Squared's in here all these points at
the baseball are different ours they're
all different points from the axis
different distances from the axis we
can't bring those out so now what do we
do well if you're clever you recognize
this term this summation term is nothing
but the total moment of inertia of the
object remember that the moment of
inertia of an object we learned
previously is just M R squared so the
moment of inertia of a point mass is M R
squared and the moment of inertia of a
bunch of point masses is the sum of all
the M R Squared's and that's what we've
got right here this is just the moment
of inertia of this baseball or whatever
the object is it doesn't even have to be
of a particular shape we're going to add
all the M R Squared's that's always
going to be the total moment of inertia
so what we found is that the K
rotational is equal to one-half times
this quantity which is I the moment of
inertia times Omega squared and that's
the formula we got up here just by
guessing but it actually works and this
is why it works because you always get
this quantity down here which is
one-half I Omega squared no matter what
the shape of the object is so what this
is telling you what this quantity gives
us is the total rotational kinetic
energy of all the points on that mass
about the center of mass but here's what
it doesn't give you this term right here
does not include the translational
kinetic energy so the fact that this
baseball was flying through the air does
not get incorporated by this formula we
didn't take into account the fact that
this baseball was moving through the air
in other words we didn't take into
account that the actual center of mass
of this baseball was translating through
the air but we can do that easily with
this formula here this is the
translational kinetic energy so
sometimes instead of writing regular
kinetic energy now that we've got to we
should specify this is really
translational kinetic energy so we've
got a formula for the translational
kinetic energy the energy something has
due to the fact that the center of mass
of that object is moving and we have a
formula that takes into account the fact
that something can have kinetic energy
due to its rotation that's this K
rotational so if an object's rotating it
has rotational kinetic energy if an
object is translating it has
translational kinetic energy ie if the
center of mass is moving and if the
object is translating and it's rotating
then it would have both of these kinetic
energies both at the same time and this
is the beautiful thing if an object is
translating and rotating and you want to
find the total kinetic energy of the
entire thing you can just add these two
terms up if I just take the
translational one-half MV squared and
this would then be the velocity of the
center of mass so you have to be careful
this let me make some room here so let
me get rid of all this stuff here if you
take one-half M times the speed of the
center of mass squared you'll get the
total translational kinetic energy of
the baseball and if we add to that the
one-half I Omega squared so the Omega
about the center of mass you'll get the
total kinetic energy both translational
and rotational so this is great we can
determine the total kinetic energy all
together rotational motion translational
motion from just taking these two terms
add it up so what would an example of
this be let's just get rid of all this
and let's say this baseball someone
pitched this thing and the radar gun
shows that this baseball was hurled
through the air at 40 meters per second
so it's heading toward home plate at 40
meters per second the center of mass of
this baseball is going 40 meters per
second toward home plate but let's say
it's also someone really threw a
fastball and this thing's rotating with
an angular velocity of 50 radians per
second and we know the mass of a
baseball I looked it up the mass of a
baseball is about 0.14 five kilograms
and the radius of the baseball so a
radius of a baseball is around seven
centimeters so in terms of meters that
would be zero point zero seven meters so
we can figure out what's the total
kinetic energy well there's going to be
a rotational kinetic energy and there's
going to be a translational kinetic
energy the translational kinetic energy
going to be one-half the mass of the
baseball times the center of mass speed
of the baseball squared which is going
to give us 1/2 the mass of the baseball
was zero point one four five and the
center of mass speed of the baseball is
forty that's how fast the center of mass
of this baseball is traveling if we have
that all up we get a hundred and sixteen
Joule
of regular translational kinetic energy
but how much rotational kinetic energy
is there so we're going to have
rotational kinetic energy due to the
fact that the baseball is also rotating
how much will we're going to use 1/2 I
Omega squared so I'm going to have 1/2
what's the I will the baseball is a
sphere if you look up the moment of
inertia of a sphere because I don't want
to do I don't want to have to do some
nation of all the M R Squared's if you
do that using calculus you get this
formula so that means in an algebra
based physics class you just have to
look this up together in your book in a
chart or a table or you could always
look it up online for a sphere the
moment of inertia is two-fifths M R
squared so in other words two-fifths the
mass of the baseball times the radius of
the baseball squared that's just I
that's the moment of inertia of a sphere
so we're assuming this baseball is a
perfect sphere that's got uniform
density that's not completely true but
it's a pretty good approximation and
then we multiply by this Omega squared
the angular speed squared so what do we
get we're going to get 1/2 times 2/5 the
mass of the baseball was 0.14 5 the
radius of the baseball was about would
we say 0.0 7 meters so that's 0.0 7
meters squared and then finally
multiplied by omega squared and this
Omega was 50 radians per second and we
square it which adds up to 0.35 5 joules
so hardly any of the energy of this
baseball is in its rotation almost all
of the energy is in the form of
translational energy that kind of makes
sense it's the fact that this baseball
is hurtling toward home plate that's
going to make it hurt if it hits you as
opposed to the fact that it was spinning
when it hits you that doesn't actually
cause as much damage as the fact that
this baseball is kinetic energy is
mostly in the form of translational
kinetic energy but if you wanted the
total kinetic energy of the baseball you
would add both of these terms up k total
would be the translational kinetic
energy plus the rotational kinetic
energy that means the total kinetic
energy would just be a hundred and
sixteen joules plus 0.35 five joules
which gives us a hundred and sixteen
point three five five joules so
recapping if an object
is both rotating and translating you can
find the translational kinetic energy
using 1/2 m the speed of the center of
mass of that object squared and you can
find the rotational kinetic energy by
using 1/2 I the moment of inertia what
if for whatever shape it is if it's a
point mass going in a huge circle you
could use M R squared if it's a sphere
rotating about its center you could use
2/5 M R squared
cylinders or 1/2 M R square and you can
look these up in tables to figure out
whatever the eye is that you need times
the angular speed squared of the object
about that center of mass and if you add
these two terms up you get the total
kinetic energy of that object